thank you good morning so I'm going to
speak about something here that is I
have main collaborator on this which is
that it was Dan Roy at the University of
Cambridge so basically when I'm speaking
here it might as well be dense speaking
and we also learned a lot from Cameron
fryer at MIT who's a model theorist so
if you if you agree with a previous
speaker that practice is better than
theory then this is going to be the
worst talk ever so what I want to tell
you about is a bit more in the line of
what what Patrick was talking about
earlier this morning and it's very hard
when you talk about its theoretical
topic to a very mixed audience it's very
hard to pitch it so I would I would like
to ask you to just can you who here has
seen the Aldo's hooba theorem before or
the definite is theorem or a graph limit
okay so that's about half actually
great so the general the general seem
that I want to talk about is so I'm I'm
gonna read a networks person I'm
interested in statistics of random
structures and what I mean by that is by
meant by random structure is something
like a sequence or graph or a matrix or
you name it but it's a random object and
now I observe one large random object
and I would like to to in some way do
inference yeah so if I observe a network
I observe a large network which I assume
is a snapshot of a huge underlying
network or an underlying population but
I just serve one let one network not
many small networks and now for them
this idea of there's this idea in which
is very important in Bayesian statistics
of exchangeable random structures and
the idea is the following so you get you
have a random structure here the X is my
random structure and it's infinitely
large okay and now I have some kind of
invariance property which is
exchangeability and if I have this
invariance property then this random
structure the distribution of those
random
decomposers in a very neat way and the
way it decomposes is in general is you
have some set of very somehow much
simpler distributions then these
exchangeable distributions are in
general so particular distributions are
very simple random structures and then
you mix over these and that way you get
all exchangeable random structures okay
so and that gives us some very important
things for statistics for one is that it
characterizes kind of the maximum
observation model of which we then
choose the sub set of models and it
explains what the parameter space is it
explains what statistical averaging is
it explains what sample size is and it
gives us a law of large numbers yeah so
here's the simplest example the
definitey theorem the simplest
exchangeable random structure is an
exchangeable sequence so that means I
get a random sequence and it doesn't
matter in which order the observations
come in it's a very simple assumption or
deceiving any simple assumption if that
is the case then the phonetic theorem
tells me I get an integral decomposition
like this and the specific form looks
like this so what this says is this year
is an iid sequence okay it's an iid
sequence sampled from a distribution
theta and this distribution theta is
retinol so this is this object here so
here this here this distribution becomes
the iid sequences with marginal
distributions theta and I'm drawing that
sida at random okay and so that tells me
that the basically the the general
observation model that I'm looking at
our distributions on the sample space so
on individual elements of the sequence
that may seems like a trivial thing but
it breaks down a very complicated object
an infinite random sequence into
individual bits its elements yeah so in
the sequence case that is not very
surprising it just tells us in hindsight
justifies in hindsight something that we
would have been doing anyway but in more
complex random structures like graphs
the results are a lot more surprising
yeah and that is exactly the basis of
what Patrick was talking
about this morning and work off Peter
Bickle 2011 in the annals and some other
recent work yeah so let me show you this
this other result that Patrick also
alluded to this morning so this is this
representation theorem for exchanging
the graphs so if I have an exchange of a
graph I get an infinitely large graph at
random and it's exchangeable that means
it's its distribution is invariant under
isomorphism okay it doesn't matter which
particular isomorphic instance of the
graph I observe to Isis and utilizing
morphic graphs have the same
distribution and the serum that David
Albus first proved in in 79 and
independently Guber and which was then
extended by calling that says is if I
have any exchange of a graph I can
always sample like this I sample a
random function which Maps the unit
square to the unit interval okay
this function has to be measurable and
we can always make it symmetric okay so
now how I do I sample my graph i sample
an instance of its sequence of iid
uniform variables and think of each of
these as attached to one of the vertices
in the graph and then in order to decide
whether there's an edge between node I
and OJ I plugged UI and UJ in my
function yeah two arguments that gives
me a value between zero and one that's a
probability and I flip a coin with that
probability okay so that's a I mean that
obviously is a way to generate a random
graph you can easily see that this graph
is going to be exchangeable yeah that it
does not depend how I label the vertices
and this year these numbers here are the
vertex labels that those are
exchangeable yeah but the interesting
thing is that actually any exchangeable
graph can be sampled in this way and
associated with that this comes in Tao
is a law of large number so I'm just
calling it a law of large numbers it's
basically the law of large numbers
this is due to chitin back in 99 and
what this says is following I sample a
graph of a finite size and now I plot it
as
a checkerboard function on the square
yeah so if I have ten vertices I decide
divides this into ten rows and ten
columns and I color them black and white
and cording to whether there is a zero
or one and zero Jason C matrix there's a
plot of the adjacency matrix but now
this is a valid function on the square
so I can sample from it with this ski
yeah and that is just uniform sampling
from the graph i sample uniformly
sampled vertices from the graph and look
at the induced subgraph yes so it's it
the the exchangeability is a property of
your data source you don't have to
observe an infinitely large graph for
this to hold you have to assume that if
you were to continue sampling then it
would remain exchangeable yeah so it's
not like it's exchangeable when you say
a value assemble the first n vertices
and then afterwards suddenly you get a
non exchangeability Benzes theorem holds
so it has to hold for the infinite
object but it's a it's a property of the
source not of the sample yeah
that's right yes so you can have you can
have finite exchange ability but that is
not going to give you the representation
zero right but in a for example in
exchange with sequence that would be the
assumption that my sequence the order of
observations doesn't matter for the
first and samples and then the drift
comes in or something like that right so
if I if I make that the assumption that
my source generates data in an
exchangeable way then this your course
whether or not I'm going to observe
something infinite yeah okay so that is
the first part and then this law of
large numbers here what this tells me is
if I now make this this graph here
larger okay and I plot it again on the
unit square increase the number of
vertices I plot on the unit square then
these checkerboard this checkerboard
pattern you gets finer right and you can
probably believe that if you keep doing
this this is going to converge to
something smooth like this right so this
is the convergence that Patrick
mentioned this morning this only holds
up to reordering though yeah so you have
an equivalency I'm going to say a few
more three more words about that but so
this is weak convergence of the
distributions defined by these objects
yeah the graph limits theory that
Patrick already mentioned by Lewis and
Sega D defines metrics on these graphs
and then looks at the convergence in
terms of this metric to a function so
graph converges to function but the two
are actually the same thing yeah so this
CA has been around for 30 years but what
the graph limits people did they filled
in a lot more theory about the set of
these functions and how they how they
work okay so what that tells me for
statistics is if I have an exchangeable
graph then I can estimate its
distribution by estimating an object
like this yeah so I can do a density
estimation on graphs basically by
estimating a function like this and
here's an example so this is some work
we did one a half or two years ago so
this is where we phrased this as a
nonparametric regression problem we know
we have to estimate this this farm
yeah so function estimation is a
regression problem here we did this in a
Bayesian way by putting a Gaussian
process prior on it okay I'm not going
to go too much into the details here but
basically just to get the idea this year
is a in input adjacency matrix of a
graph you have plotted the graph and
here is an estimate of what this
function looks like okay so basically
you can think of this as if you if you
remember how we sample from this by
throwing on these uniform random
variables yeah yeah on the on the edges
you can think of this as something like
a local edge density so if you have a
big blob here that corresponds to a high
edge density at submariner of the graph
and that would be in this case it would
be this region here of course I mean
these plots are always you know have to
be taken with a grain of salt and this
actually this idea goes back in the in
the Bayesian on permits of your machine
learning in literature for a while so
yeah I've I have a plot few plots of
models that are around in the machine
learning literature and you can see that
which are basically co-clustering models
yeah you can see that these functions
are not symmetric so this is where
people are interested in in undirected
graphs yeah undirected graphs or more
generally matrices these two models here
bird are basically reinterpreted in
hindsight yeah we know they are
exchangeable and so we can look at and
we can characterize them by looking at
what kind of functions they they
generate I would like to mention this
paper here and in particular by Dan Roy
and you by T who for the first time as
as far as I can tell invoke this idea of
of using the alders Hoover theorem in a
nonparametric way and there's some
previous paper by pieter hoff in 2007
which is the first paper I know of that
that use the Aldo super serum in
statistics machine learning
okay so now these these pictures are
some are deceiving because they are I
mean it's it's eye candy right
but these graph ones are actually these
limit objects these function C are
actually pretty nasty objects how much
until when do I have exactly all right
so there's a problem here was with
permutation invariance so what I've done
here is I've taken this this example of
a limit object I'd like to call this the
lowest graph one because it's a lesser
Lobos favorite example graph on and it's
just a minute function but it's a it's a
very simple example of a function like
this which is not just constant right if
we take this function as a constant then
we get exactly the address linear model
right so but if done here is I've
chopped up this function into ten by ten
rows and columns and then I picked a
permutation of the numbers one through
ten and applied it to each to both to
the rows and to the column separately
yeah same permutation yeah so I get
something that looks like this now if
you remember how we this the sampling
procedure my sample procedure here I
start with this function and then I
throw on uniform random variables these
are exchangeable right they're iid so in
particular they are exchangeable they
don't have a particular order and that
means that the distribution of a graph
that this defines and that this defines
is exactly the same distribution so
these two functions parameterize the
same graph so from a statistics
perspective this this Aldous Hoover fear
gives us a very nice way to parameterize
these exchangeable graphs
it says the parameter space for
statistics and natural parameter space
are these functions but the
parameterization is not unique you can
see that this is not only I mean these
are just two functions but you can see
immediately that I could have done this
with 11 by 11 blocks or 12 by 12 or
whatever right so there's an infinite
number of ways that I can parameterize
this function
and in the limit of taking infinitely
many blocks you get something that is a
measure called a measure preserving
transformation yeah I don't know whether
everybody is comfortable with that term
but basically what it says is the
distribution of the variables I throw on
here on the sides is a uniform
distribution and any any transformation
of the interval that I can can make that
preserves this distribution if I apply
that both here and here then I'm going
to get an equivalent cross yeah and it's
even worse actually the class of current
grouse is even a bit larger you can't
even get back and forth between all of
them with measure preserving
transformations and but and this is
really where graph limit theory started
to develop things that were not around
in Auto super theory yeah so and I tried
to put this together yet for you in this
diagram so this here is a set of
infinitely large graphs you know we
sample a random instance of the set this
here is a set of probability
distributions on graphs and we're
particularly interested in the
exchangeable ones now this law of large
numbers type result tells us if we if we
observe a sub graph here of size N and
we make it larger and larger than we're
actually going to get something that
converges through the actual
distribution yeah so it converges to the
specific object up to the permutation
invariance and this tells us something
about sample size right what does it
mean to have sample size in the graph
because it's maybe not immediately clear
if we just observe our tree already
mentioned this morning if you just
observe one large object what does
emphasize mean how does it explain that
by explaining conditional independence
right it breaks down the graph into
these conditionally independent edges
once we have observed this object and we
have observed these uniform random
variables here let me just go back here
when we have observed this object this
function and we have observed these
variables with I mean or we will fix
these variables that makes the edges
independent of each other and that means
if they are independent if we have
independent quantities we can average
over them right and that is what we need
to do in order to do statistics yeah we
need to do some form of averaging so
this explains what statistical averaging
means
okay so now the outer super theorem
tells us that we can take the set of
symmetric functions on the square to
parameterize to parameterize the the
measures which we can mix over to get
the exchangeable distributions okay
so but here so this is our natural
parameter space yeah this would be in
the case of just iid sequences or
exchange of sequences this would be the
set of probability distributions but
here's this somewhat more interesting
space but it's not unique yeah so
parameterization is not unique now in
graph limits theory where these guys are
mathematicians right so what do they do
they take a quotient space they say okay
we have equivalence classes here we just
mod out these equivalence classes and we
get a new space which consists of one
point where each point is an equivalence
class in this set here each equivalence
classes call up statistical point so
these objects are completely abstract
yeah and there's a priority there's no
reason why we should be interested in
them but it turns out that this space
here has extremely interesting analytic
properties and in a way this is a
central object of interest and graph
limits theory yeah Patrick mentions the
similarity regularity lemma this
morning.this fact that if you make a
graph larger and larger then it's not
completely chaotic right at some point
if you make it large enough this block
structure emerges the statement that is
the similarity regularity lemma holds is
equivalent to the statement that this
space is compact okay so that's an
analytic property of the space it's
equivalent to a deep resulting graph
limit in graph theory and you can do
that for a lot of results and graphs
like the graph theory and the analytic
properties here translate into results
in graph theory right back yeah so that
means it's unique lydian space it just
means it's a closed and bounded set yeah
so it's the but basically it's a
continuous space analog of a finite set
it's something where things don't get
out of control because the set just goes
too large
yeah but beso this is a in analytic
terms this is a compact metric space and
that is about as nice as it gets in
analysis yes yeah right so so as I
mentioned earlier these guys introduced
a metric here and that is the cut
distance right so that is a pseudo
metric that is a pseudo metric but it
becomes a metric by qualifing else
equivalence classes yeah okay and so you
have this additional type of convergence
here this is ador according to a Louis
legatee who developed this graph limit
theory the problem is so if we haven't
punctured an object here as a function
we can sample it right we can actually
generate a graph these things are
totally abstract and there's no way to
that we can sample from them so the
question the question that was open for
a while was whether we can even get back
from here to here in a measurable way so
what that means is we would like to have
a map where I stick in one of these
equivalence classes and it picks out one
specific function in this equivalence
class from which I can then actually
sample yeah and I mean you can always
invoke the axiom of choice and get that
but we would like to this map to be
measurable not totally out of control
yeah and valid ii ii and i proved two
years ago that this map actually exists
but otherwise i can't i can't make sense
of a statement like i pick an element
here at random and it induces and
distribution here yeah so measurable
finds that the non measurable functions
are the management's are so so brutally
crazy that I can't even the the image
under this function is not a random
variable yeah so because what this tells
me here is in theory at least and so far
it remains theory in theory this year is
a unique parameterization of my space
this is not unique those
parametrizations but if I could do
statistics with this is my
parameter space I would have a unique
parameterization yeah so I mean you want
to take this w at random for instance if
you are if you I mean obviously if
you're doing basic statistics in which
case you want to put on a prior but even
even if not you're still in a
probabilistic framework and and you need
these functions to be measurable right I
mean even in a frequentist setup you
would get into some kind of
contradictory contradiction problem here
because I mean you have a convergence of
this random object to this right and so
these these become random objects and
then you would like to see this also
converge here yeah so you really need a
measurable map but maybe we can beat
maybe we can continue that offline
because my time is running out very
quickly so what I just wanted to so this
this result is an existence result it's
not constructive we actually believe
that there is no constructive proof and
it's it's also not unique yeah so this
this selector here which picks out this
this element there's actually an
infinite number of them and none of them
seems to be special yeah but I just want
to illustrate with this is that these
things are funny objects we have these
equivalence classes and there are funny
objects okay
so why are they so complicated in the in
the definitive theorem in the de Finetti
theorem we also have like a structure
like this and there we sample not here
we sample a random function and then we
throw in these random variables and then
we make decisions random decisions for
the edges and the definitely seemed
really sample a random probability
distribution and then sample iid from
that right so that is first of all that
distribution is unique here we have
something that is not unique second of
all in the in the divinity theorem we
have two layers of randomness first
sample probability measure then sample
idea
that here we have three for a sample
random function then sample these
uniform random variables which impose an
ordering and then sample edges yeah so
why is this why are not all kinds of
exchangeability created equal and my my
hand wavy intuition for that is that I
think is I believe is helpful it's
appalling so if you think look at this
this general integral decomposition
exchangeable structure here then
integrate decomposition over here yeah
you can think of the exchange ability
definition yeah as putting on
constraints one by one you start with
one permutation you say my distribution
has to be variant under that permutation
then you put in a second the third one
and so on an infinite number of
constraints yeah the more constrains you
slam on here
the more specific this representation
becomes okay so stronger constraints
over here more specific representation
over here yeah now in in case of these
things struck two exchangeable
structures that we looked at sequences
and graphs in the sequence case the
index set is the natural numbers right
its indexing a sequence and the
invariance is under all permutations of
these numbers in the case of graphs if I
write them as a matrix and the index set
is N squared I have a two dimensional
object and now the invariance is only
under permutations that egged that act
the same permutation acting both on the
rows and the columns so I'm not I'm not
permuting every entry off of the matrix
I'm dressed permuting rows and columns
because that means I'm permuting
vertices and that makes sense right
otherwise it would just randomly permute
edges so that means I'm only looking at
a very special subset of permutations
and that means I'm having less
constraints here and having less
constraints here and that makes the
hypothesis of a theorem beaker so I
cannot deduce the outer suburbs theorem
from Definity
and the proof is much harder yeah by the
way the proof is also a masterpiece if
you if you're interested stuff read that
prove it sir okay
now I was asked you to I mean all right
we were asked to talk about open
problems and I mostly want to talk about
an open problem so basically I would
like to have something like this that
have just showed you but for network
type graphs yeah and this is really not
the grass we get here I really not
Network type graphs
okay so first of all they are dense yeah
they have too many edges and you can see
that very easily by taking this random
function that we take we gain one
specific instance of this function that
we sample our graph from and we
integrated over the square or rather
over the upper triangular yeah the upper
triangle of that unit square that gives
us exactly at the edge density in the
asymptotic case so the ratio of edges
that are present that are on in the
infinite graph now this is either this
function is 0 almost everywhere then
this is 0 and the graph is almost surely
empty or this is non 0 somewhere then
this is a positive number and then you
get a constant fraction of all the edges
that could be there so the number of
edges in your observed graph of size n
divided by the number of edges that
would be in the complete graph yeah that
converges to this number as n goes to
infinity and that means the number of
edges behaves as some constant times
order of N squared and that's still N
squared yeah so you get a constant
number of the constant fraction of the
edges that could be there is there yeah
now you can address that ok first of all
first of all this is not a property just
of exchange but graphs it's actually a
property of exchangeability exchangeable
sequences have this too if you take an
exchange with binary sequence and if in
any tells us it's conditionally
bernoulli conditionally iid Bernoulli
with some unknown Bernoulli parameter P
but that means that the limiting ratio
of the ones that are present in the
sequences exactly P so this again is at
0 or it's some constant fraction that is
present yeah so that is also a density
property so exchange of all random
structures in general have a density
property and you can you can address it
by what Patrick describes this morning
by attaching a rate
right so you you multiply this function
here before you sample on from it you
multiply it with a rate that depends on
it and so the problem was that is that
the that you're basically just thinning
out your graph yeah so if you sample
from a dense object like this the one
that I estimated before and and that I
estimated from this graph I'm never
going to see this graph I'm going to see
something that's blotchy right and you
can you can justify using these
approximations and Patricks framework or
imperials framework yeah but if you
really want to have a generative model
which looks like this you're never going
to get that okay you're never going to
get that with an exchangeable model so
we need some kind of invariance property
and I have to make this very quick we're
going to need some kind of invariance
property if your mantra makes as
possible that that is so to obtain a
definite it's die result for this for
for Network like structures we need an
invariance property that is weaker than
exchangeability
okay but it's stronger than this is
something I didn't get to but but there
is another kind of invariance like shift
invariance in the network you say okay
in the net I sit in a network and I look
at how the distribution of the network
around me looks as I move along the
network yeah and that is exactly what
corresponds to locally convergence yeah
but that is too weak yeah it has a limit
it has a limit theory but that does not
give us any kind of statistical
decoupling or something like that yeah
and we've been thinking about this
problem for a while we've been talking
to a lot of people about it and it seems
there's really no solution at present
yeah so this is my open problem this
helped me okay thank you very much